un début d'année encore marqué par
l'épidémie du covid 19 face à la flambée
des contaminations quotidiennes le
gouvernement annonce de nouvelles
mesures le télétravail devient
obligatoire trois jours par semaine dans
les entreprises et il est interdit de
consommer debout dans les bars et les
restaurants en politique le maire de
Mantes-la-Jolie Raphaël cogner
démissionne début janvier une résultante
du conflit qui l'oppose au président du
conseil départemental et éliminal Pierre
Bédier de nouvelles élections sont
programmées 6 candidats sont en liste
pour le poste côté sport un premier
semestre en grande pompe pour le
football yvelinois en janvier le FC
Versailles accède au 8e de finale de la
Coupe de France c'est historique pour le
club après une victoire contre Toulouse
1-0 et un succès au tir au but contre
Bergerac Versys en demi-finale mais
l'ascension s'arrête ici le club éliminé
contre Nice 2-0 sport toujours la
sixième semaine olympique et
paralympique organisée par le Comité
d'Organisation Paris 2024 et l'éducation
nationale fait son retour dans le
département cette année les thèmes sont
l'environnement et le climat à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines 600 enfants
découvrent les sites olympiques de enfin
Rima Ayadi conserve son titre de
championne continental de WBBA des léger
lors du troisième gala de boxe aux
Mureaux c'est aussi le début de la
campagne présidentielle Emmanuel Macron
a tenu sa toute première réunion
publique à Poissy sur différents thèmes
comme le pouvoir d'achat l'immigration
ou encore la guerre en Ukraine la Russie
a envahi l'Ukraine au mois de février
c'est le retour de la guerre en Europe
face au départ massif dukrainien l'État
et les collectivités se mobilisent pour
les accueillir des rassemblements
concerts et mobilisations sont
effectuées un peu partout dans le
département en plein conflit ukrainien
Emmanuel Macron réunit les chefs d'État
et de gouvernement de l'Union européenne
pour un sommet européen au château de
Versailles plusieurs décisions sont
prises notamment la sortie de la
dépendance de la Russie concernant le
gaz et le pétrole d'ici 2027 ou encore
des investissements stratégiques autour
de la défense côté culture les Yvelines
célèbre Molière à l'occasion des 400 ans
de sa naissance l'espace richo à
Versailles accueille l'exposition
Molière qui retrace la vie mais aussi
l'héritage culturel du dramaturge
Saint-Germain-en-Laye présente aussi en
couleur à la médiathèque Marc fero après
l'UVS Cussac le laboratoire atmosphère
observation spatiale travaille sur un
nouveau nano satellite inspire ça 7 sera
mise en orbite en janvier 2023 il
réalisera des observations pendant au
moins deux ans de notre terre et de son
climat à 550 km d'altitude enfin ils
nous ont quitté au premier semestre 2022
l'architecte espagnole Ricardo beaufil
qui avait notamment participé à la
construction de 600 logements à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et à la
conception des arcades du lac de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et Jean-Pierre
Pernaut à l'âge de 71 ans le journaliste
résidait à Louveciennes dans les
Yvelines